Này, 1 tháng 3, chuyển đi nhấn nước Iran đưa tin, đừng này bắt đầu của tập trận 2 quân mang tên,
sức mạnh biển vấn một bốn không bốn, kéo sai trong 2 ngày tại vì ông Man Bản Đủ Dân.
Đây là hoạt động quân sự quy mòn lần đầu tiên của Iran, kể từ sau của suông độ téo sai
1, 2 ngày bể sơ ra in hồi thằng sau.
Chông hương cô tập trận 2 quân Iran tiến 2 phóng thử như loại tên lửa hàng trình,
bởi tầm bán khăn nhau, nhằm tiêu sìa vục tiêu chim biển.
Mọi gia lực lượng ngày cũng trên khai tất nhiệm bài khung người lấy,
để phục buộc các horde động tác chiến và giám sát.
Chuy đó bộ trường có phòng án gít, Nà Xeo, gia đea trường biến.
Iran đã chương vị thêm hệ thống tên lượng mới, cho các lực lượng bốn trang,
ông Nhân Mạnh, tên Iran luôn trong trạng thái sẵn sản lối phó với mọi kịch bản của tử sai ra,
cho bối cảnh tình hình khu vực vẫn tiêm 按 nhiều bà đồn.